all right happening today we are getting
jiggy with it today las vegas welcomes
the first ever jigsaw puzzle
international convention and there's a
whole lot going on here so it's family
friendly it's helping raise money for
children with special needs and it also
is hoping to break a world record mary
jane belly is joining us live at the
convention center with more are you
going to get in on the action mary jane
[Laughter]
you know john and heather i would
definitely love to get in on the action
but i think it's going to take me a
little bit of time to put some of these
puzzles together i mean we're talking
about thousands of puzzle pieces here
not only are there competitions and
exhibits but like you both mentioned
there is not only the ultimate challenge
but also a way to give back to the
community we're actually in the puzzle
exchange area and i'm joined bright and
early this morning by alex wake nine who
is the founder of the convention and
what's really exciting for me is that
this isn't the first one that's here in
vegas but the first one ever and so we
really appreciate you choosing las vegas
i mean what went into that decision
well las vegas we'll put you on the map
go big or go home so we decided to do
vegas because there's no other place
like it this is the biggest convention
center in the world
by reputation and everything else so we
have to do it here and
running a business we do want to give
back to the community and the las vegas
community has been extremely supportive
in helping us achieve this dream so
having an autistic child myself it's uh
something that i wanted to really
support so
we
decided to set up a puzzle exchange
people come they drop off a used puzzle
and then they swap they take one from
the other table and they will drop a
donation of their choice inside a box
all the proceeds will go to new horizons
academy which provides k-12
education for the youth and autistic
children in uh in las vegas well we
really appreciate that we know the las
vegas community would appreciate that
too and what i really love is just
seeing the puzzle pieces of las vegas
here this is a 6 000 puzzle piece this
one's 2 000 puzzle piece and i can't
wait until we talk about
the thousands of puzzles we have behind
us really from all across the world that
you can't find so stay tuned to learn
more about that coming up in our next
half hour reporting live mary jane
vallieza live local now